the women that are telling you the trad wife life is amazing
are the little 22 year old 24 year old girls that just got in it themselves
I am literally just trying to be dead ass honest
being a trad wife really fucking sucks
I did it for 10 years
I got married when I was 26
I thought I knew everything
oh my gosh it was the next days of life
college was over
everybody was moving on
everybody else was getting engaged
and getting married and getting jobs and moving away
and I had the majorest FOMO of my life
the guy that I had been dating for a couple of years was like hey
do you wanna marry me and I was like um I guess so
I remember calling like every woman in my family to be like hey
how do you fucking know you're supposed to get married
like I don't
I don't I don't know what am I
what am I supposed to do
and they were like yeah
great good job
congrats you know
I was like okay
I guess this is what I'm supposed to do
but it's it's not all that it's cracked up to be
like think of yourself when you're 10 years old
and then when you're 15 years old
you really grow and change as a person
then from 15 to twenty
well when you get married at 25
at 35 you might be a different person
you know just having children alone
the gravity of that sometimes really falls on you
and you see the world differently
and you do start to change some of the ideals and morals that you had
you're gonna see the world through a completely different lens
so when you give up all of your autonomy to this other person
and then start bringing other people into the world
you may set yourself up to be in a real shitty spot
and I'm saying that with 10 years experience
and now five years removed from that experience
I've got five years to look back and say
man I really
I really fucked up
I should have stayed
and I gotta tell you
the desire that I only wish I left sooner
I only fucking wish I could have like
healed faster
but fuck I feel like I did a good job it's
so good luck